snapchat es el nuevo
sackler purdue sí, son los nuevos asesinos en masa
y ¿
cómo consiguen estos niños estos
millones de pastillas falsas que han sido
enviadas a los estados unidos desde
méxico? ¿cómo las consiguen?
será a través de las redes sociales
aquí mi nombre  es amy neville
y perdí a mi hijo alexander el 23 de junio de
2020 estamos llegando a dos años muy
rápido
aquí arriba
[Música]
y encontramos a sammy muerto al día siguiente
gracias a snapchat
[Música]
así que había un traficante de drogas en
Snapchat que se acercó a nuestro hijo con
el colorido menú de drogas
con
imágenes y colores y en la parte inferior
decía que entregó
y entonces se
conectó con nuestro hijo y entregó
las drogas a nuestra casa después de que estábamos
dormidos
[Música]
tú